let's get more now from Oklahoma Senator
James Lankford who sits on the
Intelligence Committee in the Senate he
joins us from Capitol Hill senator
thanks for being here your assessment of
this report that came out of your
committee today a lot of write-ups
saying that it goes really against the
House Committee on this this very topic
yeah that's interesting spin to say it
goes against the house committee all
that we did is we looked at the
assessment from the Obama administration
that they did in December the literally
the final month for the president that
he put out a quick run-through of what
the intelligence they had at that point
we looked at it and evaluated what they
had at that point and said yes that's
what they had at that point they
evaluated they looked at the end and
said where the Russians trying to help
President Trump at the very end yes
the bigger question was not out there
were they always trying to help the
Trump campaign no but that's not in the
report and it's not being reported on it
the Russians started working on campaign
issues in the United States in 2014 they
didn't know the candidates at that point
they determined everyone try to find
some way to be able to meddle in the
campaign they work for multiple
campaigns throughout the process so that
report looked at just those final months
and yes were they trying to engage her
in the final months for Trump sure they
were but where they threw the whole
campaign no they were not here is the
Senate Minority Leader today about this
release of the 2,500 pages that
transcripts around that Trump Tower
meeting Senate Republicans interviewed
only 12 witnesses in total an infamous
Kremlin connected lawyer was allowed to
provide only written answers our
Republican friends decided not to even
interview two of the other key
participants in that meeting Jared
Kushner Paul Mann afford to call the
Senate Judiciary Committee's Trump
Russia investigation half-hearted it's
too generous your response that is a sad
designation of what happened to Senate
Judiciary he knows full well that's the
Senate Judiciary the Senate Intelligence
Committee has also gone through this I
know Democrats are trying to be able to
make something of this this is a rabbit
hole for them they're constantly trying
to accuse and say there must be
something here that we can stir up or at
least just create an accusation that has
the appearance of it
we interviewed everybody that was there
we've gone through all the documents
everyone's story has been consistent
there was no collusion that was a part
of that meeting that was a deceptive
reach out from an individual that they
had connected to during one of the
pageants that was a music personality
they met with as a personal favor and
when you go through all the interviews
it was obvious there was nothing there
there was no reason to even report it
and go through it and my fear is that
Democrats continue to make something out
of nothing that if you look at the facts
including all the testimony today you'll
see there was nothing to that meeting
where does this go next obviously we're
waiting for the next shoe to drop with
the bob muller investigation but where
where does this all go next so the House
Intelligence Committee obviously
releases their report we're releasing
the second of our four-part report here
in the days ahead
dealing with what's happening in Senate
Intelligence what we're trying to be
able to get out as well the Judiciary
Committee from the Senate is releasing
their reports we're all wrapping up our
reports and trying to get through all
the final documents the hope is that the
Muller investigation is also drawing to
a close to be able to finish out their
investigation my fear is if you go back
to iran-contra
and the investigations of a number that
Special Counsel and President Reagan it
was six years they drug that out we want
to be able to have them do their work
finish their work and to be able to get
it done what about the concern that
Russia is going to do it again in the
midterms or 2020 we should be aware not
likely that Russia will try something
again this is something that Eastern
European countries face every single
year there's something Western European
countries have faced multiple times I
would assume the Russians did at once
they're gonna try to do it again people
just need to be aware when they see
things on social media that's not always
an American that's trying to be able to
put out that information on either side
of an issue in America and Americans
frequently are seeing social media and
assuming that's a fellow citizen and it
is not there obviously are a lot of
Democrats some others would say they're
not happy with what they saw from done
Donald Trump jr. in the committee and as
this transcript of the the interviews
are being released here's senator
Blumenthal on all of that what he's
calling for he needs to come back
testify in person under oath there is a
lot that needs to be explained the
contradictions and invasions our
paradigm record but even more so when I
attended this interview I have no
confidence you think he needs to come
back no I don't think he needs to come
back he's appeared before House
committees here before the Senate
Judiciary Committee he's appeared before
the Senate Intelligence Committee he's
done hours and hours and hours of
testimony that testimonies been
consistent they're just digging and
hoping they can find something or
leaving an innuendo that maybe there's
some secret question that they could ask
to be able to find something the hard
part is after months and months and
months of this investigation they're not
finding anything and that's really their
frustration saying maybe if I bring him
back one more time I will it's just not
there and what about the breaking news
that Rudy Giuliani has said that Muller
told him he's going to adhere to the
Justice Department guidance and there
will not be an indictment of the
president period well that's out quite
frankly that's the same thing that Jim
Comey told the president a year ago that
the investigation was not about the
president Jim Comey told the president
that three times in their meetings that
that's come out both Comey and the
president have said that over and over
again so I wouldn't be surprised by that
obviously I didn't hear that firsthand
to be able to know there's not going to
be an indictment but I wouldn't be
surprised by that because that never has
been the center of the investigation nor
is the role the Special Counsel to go
try to get an indictment of the
president it is his role was very clear
to see if there's any criminal activity
among the campaign the president never
has been listed as the source of any of
this activities or that any of those
activities even existed ever he was
researching trying to find out if
anything did occur last thing how long
do you think this is going to take
before we know a conclusion one way or
another well in the next few months the
Senate Intelligence Committee will wrap
up its work and get all of its public
information out there so that everyone
can see it and as much possible to tale
as we can get out an unclassified form
the House Intelligence Committee is
already wrapping up its report we would
hope that the special counsel would do
the same obviously we don't control the
special counsel they're independent of
us but they've gone through an
a lot of interviews an awful lot of
investigations when they wrap up and
they be able to close that they should
wrap it up rather than just keep
searching to hope to find something and
at the end of the day I think there'll
always be some conspiracy theory out
there by someone will say maybe if we
asked one more person one more thing we
would find something but I think that's
Democrats actually with hopeful thinking
against the president they politically
opposed so lifer we appreciate your time
tonight thank you